Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to the "Jump Scare Simulator"!
I'm assuming by the lovely
HD graphics that I have in front of me, that this game is gonna be a wonderful experience!
Full of clever crafting of scares and horror the likes of which we've never seen before.
So I can't wait neither can you, so let's get into it. Oh god.. Oh.
Hello...
Yeah, I-I don't know why I found this, this game is three years old.
I just looked up "Scary Games" on Gamejolt for old times sake and I found this one
*SPOOPY!*
I..
Don't know what I was expecting
No one had reviewed the game, and uh, I just thought I'd give it a go and see what the old "what for" is.
Okay. is that a button or..?
Is there something I'm supposed to do about this?
Oh.
No-OH!
God..DAMMIT!
STOP
StOp! Don't do that. Don't do that at all!
Frick
God damn it Slendypoo! Well you're not even gonna go away? You're not even gonna kill me when I'm staring at you..
Okay. Fine then. I don't know...
*Markimoo laughter*
(Not) what I was expecting..
Oh frick.. Oh God..
This is such garbo..
It's such unadulterated garbo. I wish my mouse wasn't so sensitive in this-
Fun..! That's what I'd call this game. Fun. Welp, you got me good. I will admit you got me a few times. (You mean every time?)
Yeah, good old good a good on you game. You sure did show up a storm on how to make games good
What was that and why?
Who-Who had their...Whuah...
Who had their scream cut off so abruptly?
3..
2..
1..
*weird markimoo noise*
*sigh of defeat*
You know it's not fun if it's the same noise over and over again. Can I go through the door?
*short scream*
It did it again?!
Uh wh-Oh I'm outside now, oh wonderful. Hey good at least I can play-
The thing is like when I download this game
I knew exactly what I was getting into I knew exactly what it's getting to do and frankly I changed my opinion on the matter
This this game is wonderful this game is the best and the developer like I'm sorry I didn't play this three years ago
Cuz I can't imagine coinies like I can't imagine my life without this game at this point
Like can you-can you guys imagine your life without this game at this point?
In this endeavor.. In this weird empty field.. Where I don't know where I'm supposed to go..
Can you guys imagine that just imagine? I think this is the low res version Resident Evil 7!
Oh..I know. It's a remake before the remake was actually made. Oh there's a second floor..
Yeah, this seems like the right- Oh well I'm ups- Okay, I'm downstairs again. Thought I was up then I'm down..
I'm yes then I'm no. I'm hot then I'm cold. Oh no, I'm- I'm stuck. Now I'm in hell.
Now this is hell. This is hell. I'm in hell. No I'm gonna get back. I got stuck a bit
I'm gonna play the game again, then I'm gonna have to go through all the scares again. Oh..oh no..
This time I'm ready.
Alright cool we're good. I don't remember where the rest are..
Ah.. No..
M-mm. That didn't get me.
I knew you were coming.
*SPOOPIPLIER*
Fucking..god damn it. I've already been through you. Oh, good.. This again.
Open the door.. Fuck. That's so loud..
Oh, yeah, okay. I'm back. I don't know if that was worth it. I really don't.. God.. That was actually-No.
I'm gonna go ahead and say that wasn't worth it. Not at all.
Hello? Any jump scares?
Oh- Yeah I can jump off the map, okay, well, I did that now I think the game's over.
Okay, alright.. I guess that's enough for now.. So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Hope you enjoyed this little adventure into what game development was like three years ago.
And hey, you know what, to be perfectly honest..
I got a smile on my face. So I'd say I had a good time. So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Thanks watching this short video..
I've got more stuff coming soon. My schedules been so wonky because I've been working on
something really special that I think you guys are gonna like. I'm not even talking about the big project which is something special that I
know you're gonna like, but, there's something that I've been working very hard on.. Myself, and can't wait to show you so
Thanks again, and as always..
I'll see you.. In the next video!
Buh bye!
(This is my first time doing captions and I hope you enjoy! -impalaman32)
(#RIP HEADPHONE USERS!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!)